[موسيقى]
وهذه اخبار الساعه
عدد قتل الزلزال يتجاوز الاربعين الفا
واردوغان يقدر قوته التدميريه بقوه
القنابل الذريه
وفي اليوم التاسع للزلزال 9 ناجين جدد
قضوا 208 ساعات تحت الانقاض بينهم اثنان
من عائله سوريه
واشنطن تدرس تزويد اوكرانيا باسلحه
ايرانيه صادرتها سابقا كانت في طريقها
للحوثيين
بالتزامن مع انتشال اجزاء من المنطاد
الصيني واشنطن تؤكد مجددا انه منطادو تجسس
وبكين
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه تسعه ايام مرت
على وقوع الزلزال المدمر في تركيا وسوريا
ولا تزال عمليات البحث مستمره وسط التضاؤل
الامال في العثور على ناجين وسط الركن لكن
مع ذلك معجزات تحدث اثناء البحث فرق
انقاذي تمكنت من اخراج تسعه احياء من تحت
الانقاض اليوم في ولايه مختلفه حصيله
الوفيات تزداد ارتفاعا حيث بلغت الى حدود
اليوم التاسع ازيد من 41 الف قتيل بين
البلدين الاكثر من ذلك هو ان عدد
المتضررين من الزلزال بشكل عام في البلدين
بلغ نحو 26 مليون شخص نقلا عن منظمه الصحه
العالميه بين ضحايا مشربين ومصابين
جميع علماء الزلازل اتفقوا على ان الزلزال
الاخير كان من اقوى الزلازل التي حدثت في
العالم وقدر قوته بقوه مئات القنابل
الذريه نحو 13 الف جريح يتماثلون للشفاء
في المستشفيات يعتبر حجم وشده الزلازل
ومدى تدميرها ظاهره طبيعيه
استثنائيه اتمنى الرحمه لكل القتلى الذين
يبلغ عددهم
35,418 من مواطني بلدي واتمنى شفاء
المصابين الذين تم انقاذهم الذين يبلغ
عددهم وخمسه الاف وخمسمائه وخمسه جرحى
[موسيقى]
هي حصيله ثقيله اذا تعكس جسامه هذه
الكارثه الطبيعيه التي المت بكل من تركيا
وسوريا مقابل هذه الوفيات كانت هناك حالات
نجاه انبثقت من تحت الركام فنقلا عن
الرئيس
فان اكثر من 81 الف مصاب نجوا من الزلزال
وجزء كبير منهم غادروا المستشفيات بعد
تلقي العلاج
[موسيقى]
متابعه مباشره من اليمن مع موفدين الى
هناك محمود شكر محمود اهلا بك معنا الصوره
عندك في هذه الساعه
نعم الصوره في هذه الساعه هي مثلا نعكسه
مباشره من اجواء للمدينه بعد قليل حيث
نجول في المدينه
لاول مره كما تشاهد معي هذه الصور في هذه
المدينه في هذه الساعه المتاخره من الليل
بعد ان وقفت
فرق الانقاذ او توقفت فرق العمل كما نشاهد
نعم هذه الصور للمدينه الان نعم محمود
تبدو خاليه طبعا الا من الركام هل يعني
هذا فقط في هذا الجزء ام ان المدينه فعلا
هجرها سكانها بعد الزلزال
عزيزي هذه الصور هي ستتحدث عن المدينه كما
تشاهد المدينه برمتها على الارض
قليل من البنايات هي صالحه ولكن هي
قائمه بحد ذاتها ولكنها غير صالحه من حيث
الشكل الخارجي كيف نشاهد الان شوارع
المدينه هي كيف تحولت الى ركام من حديد
وايضا من تراب ومن اسمنت ومن ورش لا زالت
تعمل حتى هذه الساعه في بعض الورش
المتاخره من الليل على ذكر هذه الورشه هل
ما يزال هناك اي امل في العثور على ناجين
كان هناك ولايات اخرى تابعنا في
اليوم جرى انقاذ شخصين هل هناك ما يزال
هناك امل في العثور على ناجين في اديمان
محمود
منذ حوالي خمس دقائق فقط كنا في احد
الشوارع الداخليه وطلب منا الشرطه ان
نتوقف وكان التوقف مرده الى ان الحفارات
ورجال الانقاذ لا يزالون يعملون وقال انه
ايضا ان نطفئ محركات السياره لان هنالك
اصوات او لربما ارادوا من صوت ما يخرج من
تحت الانقاد لا زالت الامور بين الوقت
وبين الاخر هنالك فيه امل
للعثور على ناجين الان في هذا الجزء من
المدينه نشاهد بعض الحركه يعني غير
المناطق الاخرى المهجوره محمود هذه الحركه
هذه هذه الحركه مركز للشرطه ومركز
المحافظه دخلنا من جديد ايضا على الاماكن
المه كما تشاهد معي يعني نحن لاول مره هذه
الصور ناخذها لان ولكن هذا يدفعني كي اسال
نعم
الناجين او الناجون من الزلزال اين هم
الان يعني اين يعني مراكز اوائهم الان بعد
تسعه ايام من الزلزال محمود
الناجون الان كما تشاهد هذا مخيم على
يميني هذا مخيم الان في المدينه كما نشاهد
هذا المخيم وايضا هو اقيم هنا
يعني في المخيمات في الخيام في الاساس
بشكل رئيسي
نعم نعم بالمقلب الاخر كما تشاهد معي فقط
يعني لحتى انه الخدمات انظر الى ماكينه
الاتصالات بث الاتصالات التي ركبت هي منذ
ايام معدوده انا كنا نعمل نحن جهد لحتى
نقوم بمباشر في هذه المنطقه ولكننا لم
نتمكن ساصل معك الان الى نقطه
بغايه الصعوبه
احياء بكاملهم احياء الان بك
الان احياء بكاملها على الارض
الجرافات هي متوقفه كما نشاهد
هذه الجرافات التي كانت تعمل على ايام
معدوده انظر الى هذه النقطه
باكملها هي على الارض استحاله ركاما نعم
هنالك من بنايه او بنتين ليس هنالك من
بنايه او بناتي بنايتين او ثلاثه او اربعه
برمتها محمود حجم الدمار كبير وواضح في
هذه الجوله على المباشر الان في قضيه لكن
محمود اخبرني مدام نرى ان الجرافات قد
توقفت عن يعني محاولات انقاذ ناجين على
الاغلب يعني في اليمن ما هي المرحله
التاليه الان
المرحله المرحله الثانيه هي بدايه
العمليه اخراج هذا الردم
الى مناطق خارج المدينه ثم بعد ذلك
البدء بعمليه
التهبيط او عمليه انزال البنايات الغير
صالحه والتي هي بالالاف لربما هنالك بعض
البنايات انظر الى الخدمات الخدمات على
الطرقات بس لانه بدي بدي هذا كله تقدم
الان مجانا هذه الخدمات خلينا بس لنعكس
الصوره بس معك ماذا يجري على الارض نعم
كلها خدمات مجانيه الان
هذه تقدم
نعم
نعم الاحظ كذلك معك محمود يعني انه بعد
هذه
كما تشاهد
عدا يعني المحطات هذه للخدمات يعني
المدينه كلها يلفها ظلام دامس يعني حتى
الاناره العموميه تبدو في اجزاء كبيره من
المدينه مقطوعه يعني هل يعني الخدمات
الكهرباء المدينه على الارض عزيزي
عزيزي عزيزي المدينه على الارض المدينه
انظر نحن على هوت اربعه الى خمسه كيلو
مترات المدينه برمتها على الارض ليس هنالك
لا كهرباء انظر لا بنايات لشوارع
هاي اكثر صور يمكن لربما لاعلام عربي او
محلي اخذها لانه منذ بعض الوقت نصف ساعه
اتى الارسال الى هذه المناطق انظر باكملها
باكملها برمتها بكل ما فيها هي تلاصقت مع
الارض
نعم
طيب اذا هذه جوله
لفريق العربيه في مدينه اديمان
جوله ليليه طبعا ونشاهد معكم حجم الدمار
كذلك
وغياب الكهرباء طبعا كما وصفها مفادنا الى
هناك المدينه على الارض وهي احدى الولايات
العشر المتضرره بشكل كبير من زلزال
الاثنين الماضي
طبعا اذا شكرا لك محمود
والفريق العامل معك على هذه الجوله اذا في
هذه الساعه من اليمن
[موسيقى]
ومشاهدينا بعيدا عن الحصيله الثقيله
للوفيات والاصابات فان الزلزال المدمر خلق
حاله تضامن واسعه حيث هبت العديد من الدول
الى المساعده في انتشال الضحايا وتقديم
اعانات ومساعده في تركيا لوحدها هناك نحو
تسعه الاف ومئتين وسبعه واربعين عنصرا
اجنبيا يشاركون في جهود البحث والانقاذ
وذلك نقلا عن وزاره الخارجيه التركيه
الوزاره ذاتها ذكرت عبر حسابها على تويتر
ان 100 دوله قدمت مساعدات وان 80 دوله
ارسلت فرقها للاغاثه الى تركيا كما ان
هناك خمسه دول من المنتظر ان ترسل فرقا
يبلغ اجمالي عدد عناصرها
860 عنصرا
معنى من ريف ادلبه صحفيه محمد الاشقر محمد
اهلا بك معنا اخر التطورات عندك ان كان
فيما يتعلق
بالمساعدات التي دخلت الى ريف ادلب وكذلك
اخر التطورات الخاصه
اذا كان هناك اي ناجون عندكم وكذلك التكفل
بالناجين
عن العمليات الميدان
محمد
محمد هل تسمعني محمد الاشقر في ريف ادلب
طيب انقطع الاتصال مع محمد ربما نعود اليه
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اكد المشرف العام على مركز الملك سلمان
للاغاثه الدكتور عبد الله الربيع للعربيه
ان الفرق المعنيه في مركز الملك سلمان
تدرس امكانيه اعاده اعمار المناطق
المنكوبه جراء الزلزال المدمر
المساعدات السعوديه بالعكس كامله وشامله
نحن الان نستجيب
الاحتياجات الضروريه والعاجله جدا لانقاذ
الحياه كما شاهدتم طرق انقاذ اطباء كوادر
صحيه فرق متطوعين مواد اغاثيه مواد طبيه
اجهزه كذلك بطانيات خيام وكذلك اجهزه
تدفئه يتبعها كذلك الوجود على الارض يوجد
فرق تقييم للاحتياج ما بعد الاحتياجات
الطارئه من ضمنها كذلك انشاء اولا ماوى
مؤقت يتبعه كذلك ان شاء الله من خلال
الدراسات التي تقوم بها الفرق المعنيه في
مركز الملك سلمان
بدراسه امكانيه كذلك
اعاده الاعمار
وفي حديثه للعربيه قال المشرف العام على
مركز الملك سلمان للغثه والاعمال
الانسانيه الدكتور عبد الله الربيعه قال
ان اولى الطائرات الاغاثيه السعوديه التي
وصلت الى مطار حلب الدولي تحمل
لوازميه لمساعده الفئات الاكثر تضررا
الطائره التي وصلت
صباح هذا اليوم تحمل على متنها لوازم
ايوائيه تشمل خيام وبطانيات واحتياجات
الاسر الضروريه وكذلك مواد وسلال غذائيه
وادويه واجهزه طبيه ومستلزمات طبيه هذه هي
الطائره الاولى
ولدينا عدد من الطائرات سوف
يغادر خلال الساعات القادمه
بجدوله منظمه من الرياض الى حلب لضمان
وصول المساعدات الى الاسر والمجتمع الاكثر
تضررا في سوريا
تصارع مناطق شمال وغرب سوريا اثار الزلزال
المدمره ما بين تحد كبير تكابده فرق
الانقاذ بين الركام والتحدي الاكبر الذي
قد يتمثل بارسال معونات عبر الحدود البريه
التي تسيطر عليها او تملكها سوريا والتي
قد تقف حائلا بين وصول المساعدات للنازحين
في ظل النزاع السياسي بين القوى المتصارعه
نجوا بمعجزه من بين تلك الانقاض في سوريا
اثرى نوبه زلزال مدمر لكنهم في امس الحاجه
للمساعدات بكافه اشكالها وسط مساع امميه
لادخال الاعانات برا الى سوريا التي تمتلك
ما لا يقل عن عشره معابر حدوديه حيث تترقب
كل من الولايات المتحده والمانيا تنفيذا
النظام السوري قرار فتحي مع بريبه بالسلام
والراعي لمرور الاعانات الانسانيه الا ان
الانقسامات السياسيه قد تعرقل جهود
الاغاثه ففي شمال غربي البلاد تسيطر هيئه
تحرير الشام على محافظه ادلب كما ان هناك
منطقتين تسيطر عليهما عده فصائل تدعمهما
تركيا ابرزها الجيش الوطني السوري اضافه
الى منطقه الاداره الذاتيه لشمال وشرقي
سوريا التي يتزعمها الاكراد بقياده قوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه اما دمشق وبقيه المدن
فهي خاضعه للنظام السوري
ومن ابرز ما عبر سوريا من جهه تركيا باب
الهوى الخاضع لسيطره هيئه تحرير الشام اما
معبر باب السلام والحمام وجرابلس والراعي
فترتبط بين تركيا ومناطق في شمال وشرقي
محافظه حلب تسيطر عليها فصائل المعارضه
المدعومه من قبل انقره
كل نقاط العبور تلك باعبائها وازماتها
وحجم النزاع بين المسيطرين عليها دفعت
مسؤولا بلجنه الانقاذ الدوليه للقول ان
الزلازل لا تعترف بتلك الحدود
اقتحم متطوعون من منظمه حقوق الحيوان في
تركيا مبنى سكانيا هجر بعد الزلزال لانقاذ
حياه كلب حبس سته ايام داخل الشقه شاهدوا
[موسيقى]
تعرضت مدينه حلب ثاني اكبر المدن السوريه
لاضرار جسيمه في الارواح والبنيه التحتيه
حيث لحقت الاضرار بابرز المعالم التاريخيه
للمدينه بعضها يعود لالاف السنين
الضرر لحق باهم المعالم التاريخيه للمدينه
ابرزها قلعه حلب
قوه الزلزال هدمت اجزاء من اسوار القلعه
وتسببت بتشققات في جدرانها
كذلك تضررت مناره الجامع الايوبي ومساجد
وكنائس يعود بعضها الى العهد العثماني
امتدت اثار الزلزال الى المدينه القديمه
وبواباتها المتعدده باب انطاكيا من جهه
الغرب كان اكثر ابواب المدينه الاثريه
تضررا الدمار لحق ايضا بالاسواق التاريخيه
كسوق الجوخ وسوق خان الوزير ومحلهما
التجاريه
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه بريطانيا تقدم
ادله للامم المتحده تؤكد ان ايران زودت
الحوثيين باسلحه متطوره
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم من جديد اشارت صحيفه الى ان
الولايات المتحده تدرس رساله الاف الاسلحه
لاوكرانيا سبق ان صادرتها من ايران قبل ان
تصل للحوثيين حيث قال مسؤولون امريكيون
للصحيفه انهم يتطلعون لارسال المزيد الى
اوكرانيا من ضمن هذه الاسلحه التي ينون
ارسلها اكثر من 5000 بندقيه هجوميه
ومليون و600 الف طلقه وعدد قليل من
الصواريخ المضاده للدبابات
وفي سياق المتصل اعلنت وزاره الدفاع
البريطانيه للمره الاولى انها قدمت ادله
الى الامم المتحده تثبت تقديم النظام
الايراني اسلحه متطوره للمليشيات الحوثيه
في اليمن وقلت وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه
انها قدمت الى الامم المتحده الاسلحه التي
ضبطتها وصادتها سفينه البحريه
الملكيه مونتروس كدليل يربط الحرس الثوري
الايراني بتهريب الاسلحه ما يشكل انتهاكا
لقرارات مجلس الامن الدولي
وكانت البحريه الملكيه البريطانيه قد
صادرت في مناسبتين خلال عام 2022 اسلحه
ايرانيه في زوارق يقودها مهربون في المياه
الدوليه جنوب ايران وكان من بين الاسلحه
المصادره صواريخ ارجو ومحركات لصواريخ
كروزا الهجوميه الموجهه فضلا عن طائره
مسيره مصممه لعمليات الاستطلاع وهو ما
يتعارض مع قرارين لمجلس الامن الدولي
صادرين عام 2015 وزير الدفاع البريط نفسه
دخل على الخط واكد ان بلاده ملتزمه
بالحفاظ على القانون الدولي ومستمره في
مواجهه النشاط الايراني الذي يهدد السلامه
في المنطقه واشدد في الوقت نفسه على ان
هذه الانشطه الايرانيه المحظوره من بين
اهم الاسباب التي تجعل البحريه البريطانيه
تحافظ على وجودها في منطقه الخليج
[موسيقى]
كشفت صحيفه ناروتو عن تكدس معدات ومركبات
واسلحه امريكيه في ميناء مدينه بريمرهابر
الشمالي المانيا وذكرت في صحيفه ان وجهه
هذه المعدات ما زالت غير معلومه مرجحه
انها ربما يتم توجيهها الى اوكرانيا او
تحديث مخزون العتاد العسكري لدى بولندا
ونقلت الصحيفه عن مصادر الالمانيه ان
الشحنه تحتوي على مركبات برادلي وانه يجري
نقلها الى قاعده في مدينه مانهايم
الالمانيه لتدريب القوات الاوكرانيه عليها
مع اقتراب الذكرى السنويه الاولى على
بدايه الحرب في اوكرانيا لا زال الوضع
متقلبا بين رغبه الروسيه في التقدم
واستماته اوكرانيه في الدفاع والبحث عن
استعاده الاراضي المفقوده ووسط هذا الشد
والجذب تبرز مؤشرات عديده على ان فتره
القادمه ستكون حاسمه للغايه على الميدان
وفق قاعده مصادر اخرها تقرير صحيفه واشنطن
بوست التي كشفت ان مسؤولين امريكيين
اخبروا القاده الاوكرانيين انهم يواجهون
لحظه حرجه لتغيير مسار الحرب سيما في ظل
حصول كييف على كميات كبيره من الاسلحه في
انتظار حزمات جديده قادمه في المستقبل
والتسريبات الاخيره التي نقلتها الصحيفه
حملت ضمنيا دعوه امريكيه لاوكرانيا بضروره
تحقيق النصر في المعارك المقبله لان الدعم
المستمر الذي حظيت به قد يتراجع فواشنطن
اشرت الى عدم استعدادها مواصله اغلاق
اوكرانيا بالاسلحه بشكل دائم وتاكيدا لهذا
الكلام نقلت الصحيفه عن مسؤول كبير في
الاداره الامريكيه رفض كشف هويته ان
واشنطن تسير نحو اقناع كياف ان الدعم الذي
تحصل عليه له حدود في نهايه المطاف ورغم
التطمينات بايدن المتواصله
لدعمها لاطول فتره ممكنه الا ان المسؤوله
الامريكيه اكد للصحيفه ان الوضع سيكون
صعبا في المستقبل حيث قد يصطدم البيت
الابيض بتعنت من الكونجرس
لذا فان كل المعطيات تصب في اتجاه واحد
وهو ان الاسابيع القادمه ستكون مفصليه في
الحرب في اوكرانيا وهو ما ينسحب والتنبؤات
العديده التي صدرت في السابق حول ما اصطلح
عليه بحرب الربيع الحاسمه واشنطن بدورها
نقلت الى كييف اهميه المعارك المقبله
بعبارات صريحه من قبل كبار مسؤولي بايدن
بما بمن فيهم نائب مستشار الامن القومي
ونائبه وزير الخارجيه
ووكيل وزاره الدفاع كولين كال وجميعهم
زاروا اوكرانيا الشهر الماضي
[موسيقى]
في الاثناء لا تزالوا معركته تحظى
بالاهميه الاكبر ميدانيا سيما وانها باتت
تعتبر احدى اطول المعارك واعنفها منذ
بدايه الحرب لحد الان فان المدينه لم تسقط
في يد موسكو كليا رغم الافضليه الواضحه
لقواتها على ارض الميدان كيف بنفسها
اعترفت بان الوضع معقد شمالي ضخمه مركز
المعارك في شرق البلاد ويوصل الجيش الروسي
تطويق المدينه حيث سيطر مؤخرا على
كاسناغورا وهي بلده صغيره تبعد بحوالي
تسعه كيلومترات عن باخمه اشار مراقبون
عسكريون الى ان حوالي 1500 جنديا اوكراني
محاصرون من ناحيه الشماليه من مدينه باخمت
وتحاول القوات الروسيه في الاسابيع
الاخيره تطويق من خلال قطع العديد من
الطرق المؤديه الى المدينه الحيويه لتزويد
القوات الاوكرانيه بالامدادات
معنا من كيف مراسل العربيه حذيفه عادل
حذيفه اهلا بك معنا سمعنا الكثير من
التصريحات اليوم من حلف شمال الاطلسي
النيتو في سبيل تسريع ايصال المساعدات
العسكريه لاوكرانيا جديد المواقف من عندك
مساء الخير صهيب طبعا مخبوط هي الان في
طليعه اهداف الاتحاد الروسي في العمليات
النشطه في الشرق الاوكراني والقتال
المتواصل طبعا الان القوات الروسيه هي من
ثلاثه جهات تحاصر هذه المدينه هذا ما تحدث
عنه الجيش الاوكراني وقر بان القوات تحاول
تطويق هذه المدينه ولكن ايضا القوات
الاوكرانيه تؤكد انه حتى الان لا يوجد اي
قتال شوارع كما يروج له كما قالوا من
الاتحاد الروسي داخل هذه المدينه اليوم
فلاديمير لازاري كقائد كتيبه الحريه تحدث
على اذاعه الحريه وقال ان القوات الروسيه
تروي لانها دخلت الى المدينه واكد ان
هنالك الدفاعات قويه جدا في المدينه
والقوات الاوكرانيه ما زالت تسيطر على
المدينه هنالك محاولات للتسلل الى داخل
المدينه ولكنها بات بالفشل ايضا تم نشر
بعض الفيديوهات لقوات اوكرانيه تصب هجوم
لبعض الكتائب التي حاولت التسلم الى
المدينه طبعا في الوقت الحالي صهيب لابد
هنا ان نتحدث عن حديث الرئيس
الذي قال اننا لن ننسحب من باك مود كما
نصحنا الشركاء الغربيين وهنا يتحدث عن
المستشارين الغربيين الذين اختلفوا مع
المستشارين الاوكرانيين في وجهه النظر حول
باقمه الغربيين طبعا يقولون انه يجب يعني
الانسحاب من باقوه وذلك نسبوه طبعا
يعني تشتت الجهود وعدد الهائل من الذخائر
التي ينفقها الجيش الاوكراني في الدفاع عن
هذه المدينه وهم يقولون انه لا توجد اهميه
استراتيجيه اما الاوكرانيين فهم ينظرون
الى الامر بشكل مختلف ينظرون الى ان
العمليه استمرار السيطره على باقي يؤخر
القوات الروسيه وانهم اذا انسحبوا وتقدمت
القوات الروسيه وسيطرا على هذه المدينه
هذا سيسمح بمزيد من التقدم لذلك هم
يحاولون تاخيرهم للحصول على مزيد من
الاسلحه في يعني للدفاع عن هذه نعم حذف
هذا عن التطورات الميدانيه اذا في ضخموك
لانها المعركه الحيويه الان في سبيل
استمرار المقاومه الاوكرانيه هناك امام
الهجوم الروسي على باخمت
الغرب ما يزال يتحدث على مساله التسليح
وزياده التسليح حتى اننا سمعنا ان هناك
اسلحه تم مصادرتها كانت اسلحه ايرانيه
كانت في طريقه للحوثيين سيتم ارسالها الى
الى اوكرانيا ماذا نعرف عن خطه التسليح
الغربيه وما الذي وصل من من هذه الاسلحه
الى الاوكرانيين حتى الان
نعم في الحقيقه اولا طبعا اليوم كان هنالك
اجتماع رمز شتايل وهو اجتماع وزراء دفاع
دول امريكا ودول الحليفه لاوكرانيا هذا
الاجتماع خلص طبعا النتائج هذا الاجتماعيه
يرى الشارع العام الاوكراني انها غير
مرضيه كانوا ينتظرون ان يتم الاعلان عن
تقديم طائرات اف 16 للجيش الاوكراني الامر
الذي نفاه لويت اوستن وزير الدفاع
الامريكي وقال الموقف ما زال نفس الموقف
الذي اعلنه الرئيس بايدن حول هذه الطائرات
ولكنه اكد بالمقابل انه سوف يكون هنالك
عمليات تسليم للدبابات كما تم الاتفاق
كذلك سوف يكون هنالك مزيد من انظمه الدفاع
الجوي والمدفعيه والذخائر ومزيد من
التدريب للقوات
الاوكرانيه كذلك الرئيس علق على ذلك واكد
على ان كل ذلك تم الاتفاق عليه ولكنه ايضا
اشار الى انه ذلك اتفاقات خلف الابواب
الموصله كما سماها وقال اننا لا نستطيع ان
نصلح عن جميع الاتفاقات بيننا وبين
الشركاء هذا في اشاره لان اهداف ما زالت
هي نفس الاهداف بالنسبه للاوكرانيا وهي
الحصول على طائرات حتى وان لم تكن اف 16
بدائل اخرى من انواع الطائرات المقاتله
والهجوميه هذا من جانب طبعا ما الذي وصل
سواء صهيب سالتني طبعا حتى الان
اذا كنا نتحدث عن الدبابات من
تصل الى الاراضي الاوكرانيه ولكنها في
طريقها الى الاراضي الاوكرانيه طبعا عمليه
ادخال السلاح هي عمليه معقده وصعبه جدا
ولكن ايضا في الوقت الحالي يجري تدريب
القوات بداوا بالفعل في المانيا بدات
القوات الاوكرانيه بالتدريب بدات كذلك في
بريطانيا بالتدريب في الولايات المتحده
وفي بولندا على المدرعات برادلي وعلى
المدرعات الاخرى التي يقدمها يعني الشركاء
وكذلك على الدبابات وعلى حتى ان الرئيس
زيلينسكي في زيارته الاخيره
للمملكه اقل ان سوف تبدا عمليه تدريب
للطيارين الاوكرانيين وهذا طبعا ايضا في
محاوله الدفع في اتجاه ان يتم تسليم
طائرات في الجانب الاوكراني شكرا جزيلا لك
حذيفه عادل من كيف
معركه بخموت هي الاعنف والاطول منذ بدء
الهجوم الروسي ضد اوكرانيا هجمات روسيه
متتاليه برا وقصف مدفعي وجوي حذر معه
الناتو من ان روسيا تمهد لهجوم كبير قبل
ايام من مرور عام على بدء الحرب
وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه قالت ان مجموعه
فاجنر الروسيه حققت انتصارات محدوده في
الضواحي الشماليه لباخمت وحسب مركز دراسات
الحرب الامريكي تعمل القوات الروسيه على
الاستيلاء على قريه افنفيسكي بعد كريسنا
غورا حيث يدور قتال عنيف على الطريق
السريع واصبحت بلده الشاسيفيار الحصن
الاخير امام القوات الروسيه لدخول باخموت
بينما حفرت اوكرانيا انفاقا حولها لمنع
تقدم الروس
وقالت وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه ان القوات
الروسيه تبدل تكتيكاتها باستمرار فاحيانا
تشن هجوما بمجموعات صغيره وتاره تستخدم
عشرات الاشخاص
المستنفرين في هجوم اخر بينما تكثف القصف
الليلي بالصواريخ
نيويورك تايمز نقلت عن مسؤولين اوكرانيين
مطالبه دول الناتو بذخائر للدبابات
وقذائف مدفعيه للقاذفات الغربيه لمواجهه
الهجوم الروسي الواسع كما طالبوا بطائرات
مقاتله
الوضع الراهن في اوكرانيا بمثابه اختبار
لامتلاك زمام المبادره ليس فقط لكياف
وانما لحلف الناتو ايضا الذي يخوض سباقا
لوجستيا مع روسيا قبل معركه اوسع
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه حطام المنطاد
الصيني يحتوي اجهزه استشعار تستخدم في
التجسس
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد قلت قياده امريكا
الشماليه في بيان ان الفرق المتخصصه
انتشلت حطاما كبيرا من الموقع الذي اسقط
فيه المنطقه الصيني بما في ذلك اجهزه
الاستشعار ذات الاولويه وقطع الكترونيه
محدده بالاضافه الى اجزاء كبيره من الهيكل
وتقول واشنطن ان ليس لديها شك في انه
منطاد تجسس صيني دخل الاراضي الامريكيه
قبل عده ايام من اسقاطه فيما تلف الصين
اتهامات الولايات المتح
البرنامج الصيني عاد ليتصدر الاهتمام
العالمي بعد اسقاط المنطاد قبله سواحل
كارولا الجنوبيه مطلع هذا الشهر او من ذلك
الحين اسقطت الطائرات الامريكيه ايضا
ثلاثه اجسام من طائره مجهوله الهويه فوق
الولايات المتحده يرى الاستراتيجيون
الصينيون ان في الفضاء القريب ساحه لتعميق
التنافس بين القوى العظمى حيث يرى
الصينيون ان الفضاء القريب اذا يوفروا
بديلا مفيدا محتملا للاقمار الصناعيه
وطائرات المراقبه والتي قد تصبح عرضه
للاكتشاف او الحجم او الهجم هذا الامر
اكده المحلل العسكري الصيني الذي كتب في
مجله عسكريه ان الفضاء القريب هو مجال
رئيسي للمنافسه بين القوى العسكريه في
القرن الحادي والعشرين كل من يكتسب ميزه
في مركبات الفضائل القريبه سيكون قادرا
على كسب المزيد من المبادره في الحروب
المستقبليه
عام 2019 قبل سنوات من اسقاط المنقاد
السنين في الولايات المتحده اصدر احد كبار
علماء الطيران في الصين اعلانا لم يحظى
باهتمام كبير في ذلك الوقت حيث اطلق فريقه
من طادا على ارتفاع اكثر من 60 الف قدم
وارسله ليطير في جميع انحاء العالم العالم
الصينيه قال ان المنطاد واطلق عليه اسم
كلاود شيسر يشكل ثوره في هذا المجال ويمكن
استخدامه لتقديم تحذيرات مبكره من الكوارث
الطبيعيه او مراقبه التلوث اعلان
البروفيسور الصيني هو جزء من مجموعه من
الادله التي تكشف بالتفصيل عن طموحات
الحكومه الصينيه لاستخدام المناطيد على
ارتفاعات عاليه لتتبع الانشطه الارضيه مع
التركيز على الاحتياجات المحليه والعسكريه
بحسب نيويورك تايمز
[موسيقى]
نتابع مع مراسلنا حسين طاود حسين اهلا بك
معنا يعني يبحث كل الفرضيات بدايه من
التجسس الصيني حتى الى المركبات الفضائيه
الى اين وصلت التحقيقات
تحيه لك صهيب اليوم كان هناك جلسه استماع
سريه في مجلس الشيوخ لجميع اعضاء المجلس
عندما خرجوا معظمهم كان يقول بانه حصل او
اسمح لديه اسئله اكثر مما لديهم معلومات
بسبب شرح المعلومات التي قدمها لهم
المسؤولون في الاداره الامريكيه حتى ان
بعضهم قال بانهم المسؤولين لا يعرفون
الكثير عن اصل هذه الاجسام الغامضه التي
اسقطت في كندا والاسكا في شمال الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه البعض اشار الى صعوبه
الوصول الى هذه الاجسام بسبب صعوبه
التضاريس وانها بعضها وقع في اماكن متجمده
ولذلك من الصعب الوصول اليها لاسترجاع هذا
الحطام طبعا هناك حاله من الاحباط لاحظتها
عندما كان يتحدث الجميع حاول
كبيره ديمقراطيين تشاكشومر او زعيم
الديمقرا في مجلس الشيوخ تهدئه الموضوع او
قال بان الاداره الامريكيه تعمل كل ما
عليها وعليها ان تجمع الكثير من المعلومات
تستطيع ان تحدد ماهيه هذه الاجسام التي
وقعت ولكن الحسين
في البحر قباله السحل الامريكي انه تم
ايجاد يعني اجهزه للتجسس او يعني يحتوي
على بعض المكونات التي تشير الى ان هذا
المنطاد كان يستخدم للتجسس ما الذي تكشف
كذلك عن هذا المنطاد الاول قبل الوصول الى
يعني الجسمين الاخيرين
وقال البارحه بانه لن يعطي الكثير من
المعلومات الاستخباراتيه بسبب التحقيق
وبسبب حساسيه هذه المعلومات ولكن
الامريكيون على على ثقه من ان هذا البالون
الذي تم اسقاطه في قباله سواحل كارولينا
هو منطاد تجسسي هم على ثقه من ذلك وهم
يقولون بانهم يدركون لديها هذا البرنامج
لتتجسس من خلالها شكرا جزيلا لك حسين
مباشره من واشنطن
[موسيقى]
اجواء الولايات المتحده ملبده باجسام
غامضه اربعه اجسام وبالون صيني وثلاثه
اجسام اخرى حلقت في سمائها تحركات دفعت
سلاح الجو الامريكي الى اسقاطها ومن ثم
تكثيف عمليه الرصد والبحث عن اي انشطه في
السماء قد تحمل صبغه استخباراتيه اذ تم
تغيير اليه عمل الرادارات الامريكيه بعد
اسقاط البالون الصيني ووفقا لقياده الدفاع
الجوي الامريكي اصبحت رادارات ترصد اجسام
الطيران اصغر وابطى حركه بعدما كانت ترصد
فقط الطائرات والقاذفات السريعه حاله
التنبيه العاليه اصبحت ترصد بدقه الاجسام
الاصغر والابطا والتي تنتج ترددات عرضيه
منخفضه للغايه على الرغم من ان الولايات
المتحده لم تتمكن من تحديد ماهيه الاجسام
الغامضه الاخيره الا ان قرار اسقاطها ناتج
من تزايد المخاوف من عمل استخباراتي
يستهدف منشاتها العسكريه خاصه بعد واقعه
البالون الصيني اما بكين فما زالت ترفض
اتهامها اطلاق بالون تجسسي على منشات
عسكريه امريكيه معربه عن تغاضيها عن وقائع
مماثله
منذ العام الماضي حلقت بالونات امريكيه
عاليه الارتفاع فوق الفضاء الجوي الصيني
دون اذن من الصين احدى عشره مره تعاملنا
معها بمهنيه ومسؤوليه لتظل اجواء العلاقات
بين امريكا والصين مشحونه ومملوءه بالحذر
عسكريا وسياسيا وفي الواجهه منها حمايه
الاجواء الجويه من اي رصد استخباراتي
علي السمان العربيه
[موسيقى]
تمكنت قوات الدفاع المدني في مدينه هاتاي
من انقاذ اثنين من افراد عائله مكونه من
سبعه اشخاص بقيت محاصره تحت الانقاض لتسعه
ايام كما استطعت انقاذ طفل بقي تحت
الانقاذ اكثر من 200 وسبع ساعات
[موسيقى]
الساعه انتهت اليكم تذكيرا بابرز اخبارها
عدد قتل زلزال يتجاوز الاربعين الفا
واردوغان يقدر قوته التدميريه بقوه
القنابل النوويه
في اليوم التاسع لزلزال تسعه ناجين جدد
قضوا
ساعات تحت الانقاض بينهم اثنان من عائله
سوريه
واشنطن تدرس تزويد اوكرانيا باسلحه
ايرانيه صادرتها سابقا كانت في طريقها
للحوثي
بالتزامني مع انتشل اجزاء من المنطاد
الصيني واشنطن تؤكد مجددا انه من قادو
تجسس وبيكين
شكرا لكم على كرم المشاهده المزيد دائما
يبقى على العربيه على مواقع التواصل الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]